MARIA: WELCOME BACK.
WORRIES THIS MORNING OF
POTENTIAL DOMESTIC TRAVEL BAN
REPORTS THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
IS CONSIDERING RESTRICTIONS
BETWEEN STATES DUE TO THE NEW
OUTBREAKS TO HAVE
HIGHLY-CONTAGIOUS NEW STRAINS OF
COVID-19.
JOINING ME RIGHT NOW IS GOVERNOR
OF THE STATE MANY PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN FLOCKING TO, GOVERNOR RON
DESANTIS OF FLORIDA.
GOVERNOR, GREAT TO HAVE YOU THIS
MORNING, THANKS VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE.
GOVERNOR: GOOD MORNING.
MARIA: FLORIDA HAS BEEN THE
NUMBER 1 DESTA MOTION CURRENTLY
SEARCHED ON THE TRAVEL WEBSITE.
WHAT WOULD A TRAVEL BAN
DOMESTICALLY MEAN FOR FLORIDA?
GOVERNOR: WELL, ONE, IT WOULD BE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL, IT WOULD BE A
POLITICAL ATTACK AGAINST
FLORIDA.  YOU LOOK, MARIA, THE
DEBATE OVER SCHOOLS.
FLORIDA SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN OPENED
THE WHOLE SCHOOL YEAR.
EVERY PARENT IN FLORIDA HAS THE
RIGHT TO SEND THEIR CHILDREN TO
IN-PERSON INSTRUCTION, EVERY
WORKER HAS A RIGHT TO WORK AND
EARN A LIVING AND EVERY BUSINESS
HAS THE RIGHT TO OPERATE AND
CONSEQUENTLY, OUR STATE IS DOING
VERY WELCOME PAID TO THE OTHER
STATES IN TERMS OF EDUCATION AND
ECONOMY.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE 26 OTHER STATES
IN THE DISTRICT OF COLOMBIA THAT
HAVE HIGHER PER CAPITA CASES
THAN WE DO FOR THE BULK TO HAVE
PANDEMIC.  YOU LOOK RIGHT NOW,
STATES THAT ARE HELD UP BY
PEOPLE IN BIDEN’S ADMINISTRATION
LIKE NEW YORK HAVE WAY HIGHER
PER CAPITA PATIENTS HOSPITALIZED
FOR COVID RIGHT NOW.
THERE’S NO BASIS IN MEDICAL,
THERE’S NO BASIS IN ECONOMICS,
THERE’S NO BASIS IN REALITY TO
DO THIS EXCEPT TO PUNISH A STATE
THAT IS DOING IT BETTER THAN
WHAT HIS EXPERTS HAVE
RECOMMENDED.
BIDEN IS A LOCKDOWNER AND
ADVISERS ARE LOCKDOWNERS.
LOCKDOWNS DON’T WORK.
WE HAVE DEMONSTRATED THAT.
WE ARE NOT TURNING BACK, MARIA,
AND THEY WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
GET AWAY WITH TARGETING FLORIDA.
MARIA: FLORIDA HAS BEEN OPEN FOR
SEVERAL MONTHS AND YOU HAVE
PRIORITIZED SENIORS, YOU HAVE
PRIORITIZED THAT CHILDREN ARE IN
SCHOOL.
ASSESS THE SITUATION OVER IN
FLORIDA LAST YEAR.
I KNOW HOME CONSTRUCTION IS UP,
HOME SALES ARE UP, ECONOMIC
GROWTH, HOW IS FLORIDA DOING?
GOVERNOR: WELL, AS YOU COULD
IMAGINE, MARCH, APRIL WHEN
EVERYTHING WAS GRINDING TO A
HALT.
WE HAD A LOT OF PROBLEMS LIKE
EVERYONE BECAUSE TOURISM
STOPPED.
BUT SINCE THEN WE HAVE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE LESS THAN THE
AVERAGE AND 25% INCREASE IN HOME
SALES YEAR OVER YEAR, 2019 TO
2020.  YOU LOOK AT TOP 25 PLACES
WHERE NEW HOME CONSTRUCTION IS
TAKING PLACE AT THE HIGHEST
LEVELS, PLURALITY OF THOSE ARE
IN FLORIDA.
I THINK WE HAVE 6 OR 7 OF THE
COMMUNITIES, THE NUMBER 1 PLACE
IN THE COUNTRY FOR NEW HOME
CONSTRUCTION BY FAR IS THE
VILLAGES RETIREMENT COMMUNITY
WHICH HAS THRIVED DURING THE
PANDEMIC EVEN, THOUGH, OF
COURSE, SENIORS ARE MORE
VULNERABLE TO CODE HAVE THAN THE
BULK OF THE POPULATION.
WE HAVE A LOT OF GREAT TRENDS.
, MARIA.
YOU HAVE LOCKDOWN STATES THAT
ARE PUTTING PEOPLE OUT OF
BUSINESS AND WE FOCUS ON LIFTING
PEOPLE UP BUT BY DOING THAT, YOU
ACTUALLY HAVE NEW ENTREPRENEURS
COMING TO START NEW VENTURES,
NEW RESTAURANTS ARE OPENING IN
FLORIDA, NEW HOTELS ARE OPENING
UP IN FLORIDA AND SO PEOPLE VIEW
FLORIDA AS THE PLACE WHERE THEY
CAN FOLLOW THEIR DREAMS, IT IS A
FREE STATE.
WE ARE DOING A LOT TO FOCUS ON
PROTECTING ELDERLY PEOPLE FROM
COVID.
WE’VE VACCINATED, I THINK, ABOUT
1.75 MILLION SENIORS SO FAR.
ABOUT 40% OF ALL SENIORS IN
FLORIDA HAVE GOTTEN THE SHOT.
WE ARE DOING IT EVERY DAY,
CONTINUING UNTIL WE GET ALL THE
SENIORS WHO WANT A SHOT GET A
SHOT.
THERE’S A WHOLE BUNCH OF THINGS
WE HAVE BEEN DOING FOR COVID,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME WE HAVE
LIFTED OUR STATE UP AND WE HAVE
SAVED OUR ECONOMY AND I THINK WE
WILL BE FIRST OUT OF GATE ONCE
WE ARE ABLE TO PUT COVID BEHIND
THE COUNTRY.
MARIA: WHAT ABOUT THE NEW
CONCERN OF NEW STRAINS, 350
CASES OF THE VARIANT HAS BEEN
REPORTED IN FLORIDA.
GOVERNOR, HOW DO YOU READ THAT?
IS THERE A REASON FOR CONCERN
HERE?
GOVERNOR: SO FIRST OF ALL, WE
OBVIOUSLY LOOK AT ALL THE DATA
THAT COMES IN.
THE STRAIN IS IN BLUE STATES AND
THEY DON’T TALK ABOUT DOING
ANYTHING WITH BLUE STATES.
WE DO A LOT OF ANALYSIS AND
GENETIC ANALYSIS ON STRAINS, SO
WE FIND MORE THAN PROBABLY OTHER
STATES DO.
BUT HERE IS THE THING, SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF JANUARY, VISITS TO
THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS FOR
COVID LIKE ILLNESS IN FLORIDA IS
DOWN LIKE 60%, CASES ARE DOWN,
HOSPITALIZATIONS ARE DOWN 30 TO
40%.
YOU HAVE SEEN A DECLINE IN COVID
IN FLORIDA AND OUR WINTER HIGH
WAS MUCH LESS THAN THE SUMMER
HIGH.
BUT YOU’VE SEEN A DECLINE ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY AND SO IT WOULD
BE VERY ODD TO DO A DRACONIAN
TRAVEL RESTRICTION WHICH HAS NO
BASIS IN THE CONSTITUTION AT A
TIME WHEN ALL OF THESE
INDICATORS ARE GOING DOWN AND WE
REALLY BELIEVE BY FOCUSING ON
SENIORS FIRST FOR VACCINATIONS
WE ARE GOING TO BE CREATING A
PROTECTIVE SHIELD FOR OUR
VULNERABLE POPULATION SO IF THE
SEASON CHANGES AND YOU START TO
SEE VIRUS INCREASE ANYWHERE THAT
OUR VULNERABLE POPULATION WILL
BE PROTECTED.
AT THE ENDED TO HAVE DAY, THAT’S
REALLY WHAT MATTERS.
IF YOU’RE NOT VULNERABLE TO
THIS, IT’S NOT AS SIGNIFICANT AS
SOMEONE WHO HAS COMORBIDITY OR
ELDERLY.
WE ARE TRYING TO FOCUS WHERE THE
RISK IS AND I THINK THAT’S THE
APPROPRIATE WAY TO DO IT.
MARIA: RIGHT, YOU HAVE BEEN
ADAPTING TO THIS.
WE HAVE TO LIVE WITH IT.
I WANT TO TAKE A SHORT BREAK AND
I WANT TO GET YOUR TAKE ON WHERE
THIS IS GOING AND YOUR
EXPECTATIONS AND ALSO YOUR PUSH
ON BIG TECH.
WE ARE TALKING TO FLORIDA
MARIA: WELCOME BACK, WE ARE BACK
WITH FLORIDA GOVERNOR RON
DESANTIS.
GOVERNOR, WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
THE POTENTIAL FOR DOMESTIC BAN
ON TRAVEL AND SOME PEOPLE ARE
SAYING THIS IS A CONTRADICTION
TO WHAT WE HAVE BEEN HEARING
FROM PRESIDENT BIDEN BECAUSE OF
HIS OPEN BORDER POLICY.
THEY’RE NOW TALKING ABOUT
SCREENING DOMESTIC TRAVELERS BUT
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" HAS
REPORTED THAT ILLEGALS ARE NOT
BEING SCREENED FOR COVID AT THE
TEXAS BORDER.
YOUR REACTION TO THESE EXECUTIVE
ORDERS.
>> OF COURSE, THEY ARE NOT BEING
SCREENED FOR COVID AT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
IT’S ALL POLITICAL.
HE’S OPENING UP THE BORDER AND
LETTING ILLEGALS COME.
THEY ARE NOT DOING ANY COVID
TESTS.
WE HAVE NO IDEA WHAT TYPE OF
COVID OR OTHER THINGS THEY MAY
BE CARRYING BUT YET HE WANTS TO
POTENTIALLY MAKE YOU TAKE A TEST
IF YOU JUST GET ON AN AIRPLANE
AND FLY FROM ONE AMERICAN CITY
TO THE NEXT OR HE WANTS TO
PREVENT TRAVEL TO THE STATE OF
FLORIDA.
THIS STINKS TO HIGH HEAVEN.
IT IS A HUGE CONTRADICTION AND
YOU CAN’T SQUARE WANTING OPEN --
OPENING BORDERS FOR ILLEGAL
ALIENS BUT THEN ALSO RESTRICTING
U.S. CITIZENS FROM BASICALLY
TRAVELING AROUND THE COUNTRY AS
THEY SEE FIT AND I THINK THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE THE
HYPOCRISY IN THAT.
MARIA: WELL, LOOK, YOU SAID FROM
THE BEGINNING THAT YOU WANT TO
PRIORITIZE WHERE THE HURT IS
HITTING MOST AND THAT IS
SENIORS.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO THE
STORY UNFOLDING IN NEW YORK.
WE WILL TALK WITH CONGRESSMAN
LEE ZELDIN, CONGRESSMAN FROM NEW
YORK.
YOUR REACTION TO GOVERNOR CUOMO,
AIDE ADMITTING THAT NEW YORK HID
THE DATA, HID THE DATA OF THE
NUMBER OF DEATHS IN NURSING
HOMES DUE TO COVID.
>> WELL, I THINK THAT THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT PEOPLE KNEW
MONTHS AGO.
THE MEDIA JUST HAD A DIFFERENT
NARRATIVE.
THEY HAVE ACCUSED FLORIDA OF
DOING THINGS WITH DATA WITHOUT
ANY EVIDENCE AND THERE’S NO
EVIDENCE THAT HAS COME TO LIGHT
WITH RESPECT TO FLORIDA.
I WILL SAY THAT ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT DECISION THAT IS THE
GOVERNORS HAD TO MAKE AT THE
OUTSET OF THIS, HOW DO YOU TREAT
NURSING HOMES.
A LOT OF PEOPLE SAYING YOU NEED
TO GET ELDERLY TO NURSING HOMES
TO CLEAR BEDS.
WE DID THE OPPOSITE.
YOU CANNOT DISCHARGE A COVID
PATIENT TO NURSING HOME BECAUSE
WE WERE WORRIED THAT IT WOULD
SPREAD IN THE NURSING AND YOU
WOULD HAVE MORE DEATHS IN THE
NURSING HOMES.
I THINK WE WILL HAVE ENOUGH
HOSPITAL SPACE BUT IF WE DON’T,
I WILL BUILD FIELD HOSPITALS ALL
OVER THE STATE OF FLORIDA BEFORE
I THROW OUR ELDERLY PEOPLE TO
THE WOLVES.
WE WERE STRONG ON THAT AND I
THINK IT’S THE RIGHT DECISION
AND BORNE OUT TO BE THE CASE AS
WELL.
MARIA: YOU HAVE THE DISTRIBUTION
DEBATE HAPPENING.
THIS WEEK YOU HAVE PRESIDENT
BIDEN SAYING THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP DID NOT DO HIS JOB ON
COVID VACCINATION PROGRAMS.
WHO IS REALLY TO BLAME FOR THE
ROLLOUT ISSUES?
I KNOW THAT FLORIDA HAS BECOME
THE NUMBER 1 STATE PER CAPITA
FOR ACTUAL DOSES BEING
ADMINISTERED.
GOVERNOR: SO, LOOK, THE WARP
SPEED DID A GREAT JOB AND THIS
IS A VERY DIFFICULT SITUATION
WHEN YOU HAVE THIS AMOUNT OF
LOGISTICS.
I COULD TELL YOU, WE WISH WE HAD
MORE VACCINE EVERY WEEK, BUT
YOU’LL GET MORE, BUT EVERY TIME
THEY HAD SHIPMENT FROM THE
MIDDLE OF DECEMBER TO THE
PRESENT, IT’S SHOWN UP WHERE IT
WAS SUPPOSED TO BE.
SO I THINK BY IN LARGE THE WARP
TEAM DID A GREAT JOB.
NOW IF WE GET MORE PFIZER AND
MORE MODERNA AND WE GET THE
JOHNSON & JOHNSON, WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO SCALE THIS UP FURTHER.
WE ARE HOPING THAT’S HAPPENING.
WHAT I WOULD SAY STOP BLAMING
YOUR PREDECESSOR AND TOP PLAYING
POLITICS, LET’S WORK TOGETHER TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF DOSES AVAILABLE AND
GET THE SHOTS IN THE ARMS.
FLORIDA AND OTHER STATES HAVE
DONE A GOOD JOB.
THE HOSPITALS, THEIR MACHINES
DOWN HERE NOW.
WE HAVE OTHER TEST SITES,
DRIVE-THRU SITES AND WE HAVE
THEM IN RETAIL PHARMACIES,
WAL-MART, YOU HAVE A BIG
INFRASTRUCTURE AVAILABLE IF YOU
INCREASE THE DOSES AVAILABLE TO
THE STATES, YOU’RE GOING TO GET
EVEN MORE SHOTS IN ARMS.
MARIA: GOVERNOR, LET ME ASK YOU,
YOU ARE NOW ON THE FRONT LINES.
MANY PEOPLE SAY IT’S THE STATES
THAT ARE ON THE FRONT LINES IN
TERMS OF PUSHING BACK ON THE
EXECUTIVE ORDERS COMING OUT OF
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
WE KNOW WHAT THE AG OF TEXAS IS
DOING SUING THE ADMINISTRATION
TO STOP THE DEPORTATION FREEZE
AND WE KNOW A BIT ABOUT WHAT
YOU’RE DOING PUSHING BACK ON BIG
TECH.
TALK TO US ABOUT FLORIDA’S FIGHT
AGAINST BIG TECH, THE THE
CONSERVATIVE CANCEL CULTURE THAT
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT IN THE
FIRST SEGMENT WITH CONGRESSMAN
JIM JORDAN AND ALAN DERSHOWITZ.
WHAT CAN FLORIDA STATE
LEGISLATOR DO TO HOLD BIG-TECH
ACCOUNTABLE.
WHAT ARE YOUR PLANS?
GOVERNOR: I THINK WE CAN DO A
LOT.
WE CAN SUPPORT FLORIDANS DATA
PRIVACY.
MARIA, IF YOU BUY A PHONE, YOU
THINK YOU PAID THE MONEY AND YOU
HAVE THE MOAN AND THAT’S THE END
OF IT.
THEY ARE CONSTANTLY PULLING DATA
OFF THE PHONE AND SELLING IT AND
MAKE HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS A YEAR, CONSUMERS SHOULD
ARE SR. THE RIGHT TO OPT OUT OF
THAT AND SHOULDN’T HAVE DATA
TAKEN WITHOUT CONSENT.
WHETHER THAT MEANS
DE-PLATFORMING A CANDIDATE LIKE
THEY DID TO PRESIDENT TRUMP OR
SUPPRESSING INFORMATION LIKE
THEY DID WITH THE HUNTER BIDEN
STORY.
WE WANT ELECTIONS TO BE FREE
FROM THAT AND WE HAVE PENALTIES
IN BIG-TECH TRIES TO MEDDLE.
THEY PUT THEMSELVES OUT AS THE
OPEN PLATFORMS AND THE TERMS ARE
ALWAYS CHANGING THEM.
THEY DON’T APPLY IT FAIRLY
ACROSS THE POLITICAL SPECTRUM.
THAT FOR US IS CONSIDERED WE
THINK A CONSUMER FRAUD.
WE ARE AUTHORIZING SUITS UNDER
OUR CONSUMER FRAUD STATUTE TO BE
ABLE TO FOR INDIVIDUAL FLORIDANS
TO BRING AGAINST BIG TECH IF
THEY GET CENSORED OR
DEPLATFORMED AND OUR STATE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO DO IT AS
WELL.
SO THEY NEED TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
THEY HAVE WAY TOO MUCH POWER AND
THEY ARE NOT USING IT IN A WAY
THAT’S CONSTRUCTIVE TO OUR
SOCIETY.
I THINK WE’VE HAD A LOT OF
INTEREST FROM OTHER STATES.
THEY’LL THERE A LOT OF OTHER
STATE THAT IS FOLLOW FLORIDA’S
LEAD.
YOU DO NEED TO DO THINGS LIKE
YOU TALKED WITH CONGRESSMAN AND
THERE’S A LOT THE STATES CAN DO
BUT WE WILL PURSUE THAT IN THE
STATE OF FLORIDA.
MARIA: YOU’RE PURSUING ALSO
ALONG THE LINE IT IS RULE OF LAW
AS IT RELATES TO RIOTING, RIGHT?
YOU HAD MENTIONED THE LAST TIME
WE SPOKE THAT YOU WERE GOING TO
DO SOMETHING THIS UPCOMING
MARCH.
GOVERNOR: LEGISLATURE MEETS
MARCH SECOND AND WE H HAVE THE
STRONGEST ANTILOOTING AND
ANTI RIOTING.
I DON’T CARE WHAT TEAM YOU’RE
ON.
IF YOU’RE DOING THINGS LIKE
LOOTING, ASSAULTING COPS THAT WE
SAW OVER THE SUMMER IN MANY
CITIES IN THE COUNTRY, IN
FLORIDA YOU’RE GOING TO JAIL FOR
THAT.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO TOLERATE IT
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO PASSING
THAT AND IT WILL BE GOOD FOR THE
STATE.
MARIA: THANK YOU SO MUCH, WE